hello everyone how's it going my name is
mayuko and welcome back to my channel
all right so today i wanted to talk
about is software engineering a long
term career some of you are currently
trying to break into the industry or are
really considering it and others of you
have already put time in as a software
engineer and you're thinking is this
something that i can keep doing for 10
20 30 years the spoiler here is that yes
a career in tech is something that you
can do long term but today i wanted to
dive into the specific parts of why to
do this i'm going to introduce you to
some different perspectives from tech
veterans from across the industry so
that by the end of the video you can
answer for yourself whether this is a
career you want to do long term and
before we move on i wanted to say thank
you to formation for sponsoring today's
video they have an incredible training
program for engineers with a few years
of experience who want to level up their
skills and we recently just announced a
scholarship the my yugo x formation
diversity scholarship which will cover
the full tuition a value of 7 500
to their interview prep program this
program helps engineers fill specific
skill gaps get mentorship from super
senior engineers and get referrals
directly into the top companies in the
industry in fact all of today's guests
are part of the formation team where
they help mentor and advise their
students so if you like what these
people have to say chances are you're
gonna like the program the program was
founded by former nextdoor and meta
engineers it's three to six months long
you can do it part time and they also
offer an income share agreement so you
can pay zero until you get the job you
can check out their program and apply
for free at formation.dev
myuco also linked in the description box
you can also check out the scholarship
linked below thank you again so much to
formation for sponsoring now let's get
back to the video so is software
engineering a long term career let's
find out i actually started uh the
industry out of college back in 2013. so
i went to uc davis up in northern
california almost nine years now i
definitely feel like there's a lot of
opportunity in the industry it's a
growing industry so ever since
graduation i graduated in 2012 so it
will be 10 years
not counting internships yeah i think
it's definitely a long time career i
know so many people and i have so many
colleagues who have celebrated their
five-year 10-year 20-year in the in the
same job as some sometimes even like in
the same team i also
asked them before and of course you know
they're good faces and bad faces they're
like moments of doubts for everybody
i
first got into tech when i was a
freshman in college
so that would have been
95 pushing 25 years well if the careers
of these three people is any testament
it definitely is and i mean there's a
lot to love about the job the
compensation is typically good enough to
sustain a comfortable standard of living
you can have a lot of impact with the
code that you're writing also a lot of
companies are allowing you to work more
flexibly in terms of location and work
hours and there's always new stuff to
learn in short it pays well it's
rewarding it's flexible and it stays fun
because there's always new stuff but
typically when people are thinking about
whether a career is long-term they're
thinking of a couple of different
factors one is the stability and growth
of the industry that they're in and the
other is whether the job is like
interesting enough for lack of a better
phrase to continue doing for many many
years so first let's talk about that
stability and growth part this means
things like is this industry going to
continue to exist for many years and are
they going to keep hiring or is it a fad
like will it be replaced by automation
or maybe the need for that role is just
going to completely disappear i feel
like since i was in college you know
coming into the industry about nine
years ago companies were talking about
like a shortage of either
software engineers or just programmers
in general right and as i kind of
alluded to you know you can be a
programmer and not even necessarily be
working in the software industry right
like there are biologists that write
code civil engineers mechanical
engineers you know it's specifically
coming into you know the software
engineering industry there's always more
these days that companies are trying to
do and you know long gone are the days
where you might have one person or two
people writing the code for you know
some massive software or some some super
useful software at this point the
expectations are very high and if you're
making software people expect it to have
a lot of functionality so we have
massive teams at this point even if like
a your direct team is maybe eight people
nine people we're part of a larger
organization so i just feel like there
are so many opportunities and the
industry is only growing that's office
an engineer at metta who works in vr
who's had a prolific career in gaming
and what he says completely tracks i
mean if we think about the amount of
technology that we use and depend on in
our daily lives over time then really
it's only gone up new apps services
games products are coming out every
single day to improve things in our
personal lives our workflow or health or
are just downright interesting even in
our economy right now we're hiring
freezes and layoffs are routine there's
still going to be a continued demand for
software engineers it's it's just
there's always going to be like people
who
a need for people who can think about
complex systems design creative
solutions creatively think about
problems and that's daniel he's been
working in software for a long time most
notably at microsoft and meta and he's
seen how the industry has changed since
like the 90s a lot of things have gotten
easier
right the production the time to to
completion or time to market for a new
novel
system
is a lot smaller and so i think
productivity will continue to go up and
what software engineers
do might look different but i don't
think the need for software engineers is
going to go down these days there's
software in everything from household
items like microwaves or like dog toys
or even key fobs to public services like
train schedules or car registration
renewal systems or maybe like checking
out a book at the library not to mention
software is also used in a lot of
life-threatening and life-saving
situations as well things like
calculating the rate of climate change
by measuring icebergs using machine
learning to monitoring glucose levels
and alerting caregivers and patients
about anomalies and that's honestly one
of the best parts about this industry
like the fact that you can apply your
skills to a breadth of different topics
so there are just many different
combinations of positions and roles and
responsibilities that people can gain
within the tag bubble and that's cherry
hertz an engineer turned engineering
manager who's worked in cloud and
infrastructure for the past decade
thinking about the length sometimes
could freak you out uh versus thinking
about you know what is the next
excitement for me like what is the next
thing that i want to do try not to limit
yourself with the specific field or the
specific
theme of this company that you've worked
for and this kind of goes into like that
second factor of whether software
engineering is a long-term career like
does it stay interesting enough and i
think cherry's advice here is awesome
because it's a mindset that i hear from
like seasoned engineers about staying in
this career long term and that's around
the spirit of exploration and curiosity
there are different paths to get into
the industry and then depending on the
path you take you're
open to different areas right so you
have more mobility i think if you go the
college route et cetera but there are
still a lot of things you can do even if
you don't go that route because there
are a lot of companies who just need
people that can write code for example i
think that being intentional about what
you want to do is super helpful because
we're people we get bored you know like
it doesn't matter how much you enjoy
what you're doing if you're doing it for
like 10 15 years you're gonna want to
try something new so i think at that
point branching out and being open to
learning because there are always new
things happening in the industry and i
think that if you're open to learning
and willing to go and try to pick those
things up you can branch out and jump
into a new area and that will keep
things fresh and prevent you from
feeling
like you've been doing the same thing
i find that the problem's fun i find the
people really fun i've crossed paths
with a lot of really awesome wonderful
people so yeah when we look at software
engineering is definitely a long-term
career
but something that i realized recently
is that it doesn't seem like there's a
lot of software engineers out there with
like over 20 years of experience and i
was thinking about this because when
this question first popped up of like
whether this is a long-term career i
realized that in the general landscape
of things it felt like most software
engineers out there had like 10 or less
years of experience this 2022 annual
survey from stack overflow also shows
similar results where most of the survey
respondents have had 10 years or less of
coding experience and that got me
thinking are people leaving the industry
when they get to a certain level or is
it that there's a huge number of new
people coming in that the median years
of experience just tends to skew lower
my hypothesis
is that the median time in in the
software industry or in tech is low
because of people coming in what
business these days does not need
some amount of software engineering like
even if it's just like you're a mom and
pop i don't know you store on etsy even
right you like you you're crafty but you
need a web presence to sell your thing
for as long as the demand for software
engineers is increasing that's going to
very easily allow it to continue to be
lopsided on the junior side but then
there's something else
interesting at play here as well like
you mentioned you know junior to
eventually senior to the staff
not everyone is going to get to staff
and nobody should want everyone to get
to staff i don't think that should be a
goal right you're always going to need
more people on the ground like doing the
work that you need like
chefs and you know calling the shots and
this makes sense because university
computer science programs are like
bursting at the seams there's a lot of
great boot camps out there these days
and online resources for teaching
yourself how to code are readily
available more than ever before and so
it would not be an understatement to say
that there are way more software
engineers at the junior level than ever
before which you know is a good sign
that this industry is continuing to grow
so anyway careers are a highly personal
thing i think for most people these days
some people do their life's work at
these jobs and even if you don't you
spend a non-trivial amount of time being
a software engineer doing that work
especially if you look at it over a long
period of time and luckily because of
how healthy the industry is software
engineering is something that you can
bounce back and forth between with some
people going into things like product
management or ux design for a few years
and others stepping way out to things
like youtube or like baking or comedy or
anything else like completely different
and so i wanted to ask cherry daniel and
offies their advice on what it takes to
have a long-term career in software
engineering career means different
things to everybody i think would say to
be able to really have a career that you
enjoy or like that this
as a part of your life you have to kind
of calibrate it with other aspects that
you care about does it really make you
happier if you work on a different
project every year and make an impact on
those 10 20 30 projects or does it make
it happier that
you grow with the team with the product
with the company uh and and and see you
know every phase of that product or that
team is making sure that you take breaks
uh there have been i haven't even been
in the industry for that long but there
have been times where i've felt burnt
out you know that's during my nine years
in the industry and it's because like i
mentioned you know the work isn't easy
it's tiring there are times where you
will be up late at night
so making sure that you take that time
for yourself whether it's just taking a
vacation or even just taking a day off
to just sit in your house or your
apartment and relax and then on top of
that i'd say networking networking has
been invaluable like since college and i
was actually taught that pretty early
because i was super shy in short i'll
summarize i don't remember the whole
story but i wanted to talk to somebody
and i was shy and i was part of nesbi in
college and nozbe is like the national
society of black engineers and the
president at the time said it's what
defines you i said you know what that's
a good point so i went and i talked to
the person and then you know like just
from that point on i feel less shy you'd
be surprised you know how i was able to
like get into some of these companies
just because so and so that i met
randomly at a conference or just said hi
to at some event happened to work at
this place and they were like oh hey
come come check out my company you know
and i went i met people and then it was
when i was looking for something new you
know i was able to just reach out to
this person and interview you know so i
think that networking is huge this is
going to be highly personal it's two
things one is um hopefully obvious to
most people which is work-life balance
if your job is everything
you're setting yourself up for all kinds
of badness you know if if the job
doesn't work out for some reason then
and your and your whole self is sort of
wrapped up in that you can have a harder
time adapting to coming up with
something new but also just
having having balance in life will make
things more sustainable the second thing
is have high expectations
for
the
types of leaders
in your organizations and don't put up
with toxic environments you know that
don't work for you and what doesn't work
for you might be different than what
doesn't work for me people are
introverts and extroverts as a simple
breakdown the kind of work situation
where
person a will thrive is going to be
different from where person b will
thrive you learn about yourself and the
kinds of teams that you work best in and
find those teams thank you so much for
watching this video and thank you so
much to cherry daniel and offies for
being a part of this video again make
sure to check out the mayuko exformation
diversity scholarship in the description
box down below i am so so excited to
bring this to you applications are due
august 19 2022. and as always make sure
to subscribe to this channel if you
haven't done so already and i will see
you next time bye
[Music]